لقد تجاوزتم جميع حدود اللباقه وتعديتم
الخطوط الحمراء هكذا اعلنها الكريم في وجه
البيت الابيض وانسكي يدعو مجلس الامن
الدولي لعقد جلسه طارئه لم نشكل تحالفا
عسكريا مع الصين ولدينا مئات من قنابل
اليورانيوم المنظم لم تستخدم بعد فهل من
هدف محدد يا هذا واوكرانيا تعلن بيلاروسيا
رهينه نوويه والعالم يحبس انفاسه بسبب
حقيبه بوتين المرعبه والطائرات الاوكرانيه
تضرب مجددا في الاراضي الروسيه الاف
المدنيين ينضمون للجيش الاوكراني فهل
انتهى العسكريون الصين تسيطر على اقتصاد
العالم وصندوق النقد الدولي يؤكد وحرب
التكنولوجيا تشتعل بين بكين واشنطن
والانقسامات تندلع في الكيان الاسرائيلي
وترامب اعظم التهديد للولايات المتحده
ليست روسيا او الصين روسيا تبدا ردها
القاسي
تمضي بنجاح والتخطيط الغربي لم ياتي بجديد
وكذلك العقوبات الغربيه عادت على اصحابها
بنتائج عكسيه يعترف الغرب ان عقوباتهم
المناهضه لروسيا لم تؤتى ثمارها بل وفتحت
افاقا جديده للتعاون بين موسكو وبكين بدلا
من تدمير الاقتصاد الروسي وفقا لصحيفه
الالمانيه لياتي الدور على الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين ليعلنها صريحه بقوله ان
الغرب هو الطرف الذي يبني محورا عسكريا
جديدا وليست روسيا او الصين مشيرا الى ان
التعاون مع الصين لا يشكل تهديدا للغرب
ليوجه رجل الكرملين الاول رساله مباشره
وجهتها هذه المره هي بريطانيا قائلا ان
روسيا لديها الم من قنابل اليورانيوم
المنظم التي لم تستخدمها بعد وكانه يقول
اذا اردتم رؤيه قنابلنا بل تزودوا
اوكرانيا بالقنابل وعندها سنمطر سماءكم
بقنابلنا قبل ذلك كان بوتين قد اعلن نشر
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا موضحا
اكتمال بناء منشاه تخزين للاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا بحلول يوليو
المقبل هناك جنه جنون الغربيين فالبيت
الابيض والبنتاجون يعتبرونها مراوغه
سياسيه من الكرملين بينما قال حلف النيتو
انه متيقظ ويراقب الوضع والتطورات اما
اوكرانيا فقالت ان روسيا تحتجز بيلاروسيا
رهينه نوويه ليعود البنتاجون مطمئنا بانه
لا وجود لمؤشرات بشان استعداد روسيا
لاستخدام اسلحه نوويه اما الحكومه
الاوكرانيه فدعت الى اجتماع طارئ لمجلس
الامن الدولي من اجل بحث خطه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لنشر اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا بينما حتى مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بيلاروسيا على عدم نشر اسلحه نوويه
روسيه على اراضيها لانها ستواجه المزيد من
العقوبات بحسب تعبيره فخرج لهم بوتين
مجددا ليقول انه لا شيء غير اعتيادي هنا
الولايات المتحده تفعل ذلك منذ عقود هي
تنشر منذ زمن طويل اسلحه نوويه التكتيكيه
على اراضي حلفاي وتابع اتفقنا على القيام
بالامر نفسه مؤكدا الحصول على موافقه
بيلاروسيا اذا ما الذي تخطط له يا هذا
لتاتي الاجابه بسيل من التقارير العالميه
وجميعها تشير شيء واحد نعم انها تلك
الحقيبه حقيبه بوتين النوويه وهي احدى
اخطر الحقائب في العالم ان لم تكن الاخضر
تبقى تحت اشراف ضابط امن مسلح يرافق بوتين
في حله وترحاله لا يمكن فتحها الا برموز
سريه تخضع للرقابه 24 ساعه على مدار اليوم
فيها زر واحد فقط يعرف باليد الميته فاذا
احس بوتين بالتهديد وجودي لروسيا يمكنه
فقط ضغط ذلك الزر ليتم اطلاق الاسلحه
النوويه من جميع مستودعات الاسلحه الروسيه
هذه الحقيبه ليست وحيده فهناك اثنتان
اخريان واحده لدى وزير الدفاع واخرى لدى
رئيس هيئه الاركان العامه فان بوتين لن
يدعى عمله للصدفه وسياتي الرد الروسي حتما
حتى لو لم يكن بوتين موجودا حينها وهنا
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سرجي يؤكد ان شاشه
البيت الابيض تجاوزوا جميع حدود اللباقه
الدبلوماسيه والاخلاقيه على حد سواء ولا
يستبعد تجاوزهم لحدود اخرى وفق قولها وزير
الخارجيه الصين لان العلاقات الثنائيه بين
روسيا والصين هي القوه التي ستحقق السلامه
والاستقرار العالميين مؤكدا ان العلاقات
بين البلدين لا تشكل تهديدا لايه دوله ومن
استعدادات الحرب النوويه الى حرب اوكرانيا
التقليديه حيث قالت صحيفه
البريطانيه ان القوات الاوكرانيه تخسر من
100 الى 200 عسكري يوميا خلال المعارك
الدائره حول مدينه ارتيموفيسكا وجيش
الاوكراني يفقد افراده تباعا فكيف
سيستمرون بالمقاومه لتاتي الاجابه منك هذه
المره ارتفاع وتيره الحرب في الجبهه
الشرقيه سته الويه تضم الاف المدنيين
التابعين لوزاره الداخليه الاوكرانيه
تستعد للانضمام لقوات الجيش على الجبهات
مطلع الشهر القادم اي ان اوكرانيا اصبحت
تقاتل بجنود الداخليه والامن هناك هكذا
اوليكسس كين مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
الاسبق ان الدول الاوروبيه متعبه من اثر
العقوبات التي فرضتها ضد موسكو وتريد بدء
الرئيس الاوكراني
[موسيقى]
مخازنهم تنضب واقتصاداتهم تنهار ولم
يحققوا نتائجهم المرجوه وكانه قد حان وقت
الاستسلام اليس كذلك يا اصدقاء لكن يبدو
انك ترفض الاستسلام وها هي تستفز الدب
الروسي مجددا حيث اعلنت خدمه الطوارئ في
مدينه تولا الروسيه عن اصابه شخصين جراء
انفجار كبير ضواحي مدينه تولا التي تبعد
200 كيلومتر جنوب العاصمه موسكو هذا
الانفجار جاء بضربه من مسيره اوكرانيه من
طراز تيو محمله بالمتفجرات وفق وكاله تاس
الروسيه الخنف الصيني العظيم
قائمه الحلفاء الصينيه اصبحت تعمل
كالمغناطيس لتتساقط عديد الدول في الاحضان
الصينيه ودون عناء هنا ساعات قليله فصلت
قرار دروس بقطع علاقات الدبلوماسيه مع
تايوان حتى اعلنت الصين اقامه علاقات معها
لتنضم الى قائمه دول اعلنت مؤخرا عن ذات
الخطوه بعد وعود صيني وهنا ياتي سبب تهافت
الدول على الحلف الصيني حيث قالت
كريستالينا جورجيفا مديره صندوق النقل
الدولي فان حصه الصين في النمو الاقتصادي
العالمي ستبلغ الثلث في عام 2023
هذا الانتعاش القوي للاقتصاد الصيني سيعطي
دفعه ايجابيه للاقتصاد العالمي وفق قول
جورجيفه لكن اصحاب العيون الضيقه لا ينسون
حربهم ضد الامريكان حتى في مجال
التكنولوجيا وهنا الخارجيه الصينيه تشدد
على ان واشنطن لم تقدم اي دليل حتى الان
يثبت ان تطبيق تيك توك يهدد الامن القومي
الامريكي دعايه واشنطن الى احترام مبادئ
اقتصاد السوق والمنافسه العادله والتوقف
عن قمع الشركات الصينيه وفق بيان الوزاره
الصينيه جاء هذا الرد الصيني بعد جلسه
استجواب غير مسبوقه لرئيس التيك توك
التنفيذي في الكونجرس الامريكي نعم يا
ساده فعلاقه بكينج واشنطن تتجه نحو طريق
المسدود فماذا بعد هذا كله يا هؤلاء
الاحداث والتطورات
نشطونا يقتحمون بنك بوكليزل البريطاني
بمدينه مانشستر الانجليزيه احتجاجا على
مساهمته بتمويل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نتنياهو يقيل وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
بعد ان اعلن رفضه للتعديلات القضائيه
مطالبا نتنياهو بتعليق العمل بها اعلن
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن شنغارات دقيقه
ضد مقاله انها منشاه تستخدمها جماعات
تابعه بايران شمال سوريا مضيفا انه مستعد
لمزيد من الاجراءات لترد طهران انه لا
اساس للاتهامات الامريكيه ولا ادله عليها
مؤكده بانها سترد على اي هجوم ستتعرض له
قواعدها في سوريا قال دونالد ترامب ان
التهديد الاكبر لامريكا ليست الصين او
روسيا ولكن كبار سياسيين الامريكيين من
بينهم الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيسه
مجلس النواب السابق مانسي بيلوسي روسيا
تشرع باول خطوه نوويه فهل تكتفي بذلك من
الحرب النوويه قائمه لا
[موسيقى]